la siguiente tabla muestra los valores
de los puntos x
de la gráfica de una función lineal
determine la intersección en de esta
gráfica
vemos que la intersección en james si se
imaginan una línea en una gráfica como
la que voy a poner ahorita tenemos aquí
el eje y el eje x los marcamos y x e
imaginamos nuestra línea que va más o
menos así la intersección en g va a ser
cuando x vale 0 así que la coordenada de
este punto de acá va a ser cero porque x
vale cero coma y bueno aún no sé qué
valor vaya acá pero va a ser un valor de
ella cuando alguien pregunta por la
intersección en lo que les pregunten en
realidad es cuál será la coordenada
cuando x es igual a 0 viendo la tabla
encontramos el valor cuando es igual a 0
2 0
esta es la intersección en x ésta es la
intersección en x que ese día está de
acá pero la que nos están pidiendo es la
intersección en que ponemos la de x de
todas maneras es 20 y bueno vemos la
tabla no nos da ningún valor aquí donde
que sea igual a 0 pero quizás nosotros
lo podemos inferir usando los valores
que nos dan voy a reescribirse tabla
para tener un poco más de espacio para
escribir otros puntos que quiero inferir
vamos a escribir la de este lado para
que no se confundan tenemos aquí
el espacio para la tabla aquí va a ir de
coordenadas x aquí baila coordenadas y
escribimos bueno de menos 28 menos 28
ahora yo quiero calcular cuál será la
coordenada para menos uno en x para 0 en
x y bueno aquí retomó los valores que ya
me están dando que es 12 20 y 4 menos 4
qué pasa cuando x pasa de 1 a 2 cuando x
aumenta el 1 aquí aumenta en 1 qué pasa
con el valor de g puesto que vamos de 2
a 0 de aquí a que se restan 2 o se de
crem en tan 2 y como esta es una línea
la pendiente va a ser constante es decir
el cambio en ye con respecto al cambio
en x no va a cambiar de manera similar
cuando x es menos 2 y queremos que pase
a menos 1 es decir aquí aumenta 1 qué va
a pasar con y pues ya vemos que esto es
constante se va a decrementar en 2
entonces este 8 le vamos a quitar 2 y
aquí que nos va a quedar nos va a quedar
un 6
sigamos ahora si de -1 incremento a 1
aquí le sumó 1 me va a quedar en cero se
sigue cumpliendo ahora a este 6 le tengo
que restar 2 para mantener el cambio
constante que pasa cuando le restó 2 a 6
me va a quedar 4
04 ahora cuando 0 el aumento uno de aquí
acá tiene un uno agregado pues aquí se
está cumpliendo este 4 le restamos 2 y
nos quedan 2
así que esto se está cumpliendo ahora
que pase cuando esté 2 le agrego 22 le
agregó un 1 le agregó 2a pues aquí se va
a incrementar de 0 a 4 se va a
decrementar en menos 4 le vamos a quitar
4 que sigue cumpliendo esta proporción
entonces lo que se mantiene constante es
el cambio el cambio en con respecto al
cambio en x esta vuelta este triangulito
de aquí se llama delta es una letra
griega que indica cambio el cambio en x
entre el cambio y se mantiene constante
y vimos que esto es igual cuando se
cambia en menos 2
- 2x va a cambiar en 1 en una positiva
así que esto es menos 2 y de hecho ya
respondimos lo que nos pedían sin darnos
cuenta puede ser valor de james cuando x
es igual a cero pues es 4 es este 4 que
ahora lo podemos sustituir acá 4 y esta
es mi intersección en y aquí vale 4
aunque no gráfica mos esta escala esto
lo dibujé como quien dice a ojo de buen
cubero vamos a hacerlo un poquito más
apegado a la realidad tengo mis ejes
x los etiquetó para no confundirnos de
equis y ahora vamos a ver las
proporciones vimos que este es en la
coordenada 2 de x vamos a ver
23 45 este es el 2 y vamos a hacer lo
mismo con estos 1 2 3 4 5 6 y este es
uno dos tres cuatro
la coordenada 20 es esta 20
y lo pongo en otro color aquí para que
se note y la coordenada 404 no no es 4 0
no no no no no la coordenada cero ya que
x es 004 ok ahora sí entonces si unimos
estos dos puntos ahora sí voy a tener
una recta parecida o bueno más realista
con respecto a estos datos entonces
unimos este punto con este más o menos
por acá y lo voy a extender para que se
note mejor ok y esta es la línea que nos
están indicando con esos puntos de la
tabla